Okay, so I've got the website open.
Let's go ahead and
try it out in dev tools, I'll open it up by pressing Cmd+Option+I and
let's go ahead and just select one of these rows.
Sure, row and here we go.
Now I'm going to answer this a little bit out of order.
We should see changes immediately.
As soon as we start typing in here.
So display and the first one was block.
Press Enter and it looks like nothing happened up here.
Okay, so I'm not feeling too good about block.
Let's try float.
We'll just go ahead and jump to that.
Go to F-L-O-A-T and press Enter.
Oh, okay so that's being invalidated by something.
Okay. So that's not working.
Let's try instead, display flex.
Hey, hey.
And look at that.
As soon as we do it, our columns look right.
2 and 10 are lined up.
3 and 9 are lined up.
4, 4, 4.
They're acting like we expected them to.
And of course, we can also add flex wrap, wrap.
And it still looks good.
To learn more about flex and
the way it works, check out the link in the instructor notes.
This means that display: flex; flex-wrap: wrap, is the correct answer.